salut aujourd'hui on va parler d'un tout
nouveau téléphone qui vient sortir c'est
[Musique]
htc hub oms acheter sinon c'est le
nouveau téléphone effectivement de la
marque htc htc qui est une marque
taïwanaise jusque là tout va bien alors
le htc lyon c'était un des téléphones
vraiment attendue en 2017
parce que htc est une énorme marque ils
font des super produit et ce htc aux il
faut dire que il tient ses promesses
mais il ya un truc qui dérange téléphone
un passement tient déjà pour commencer
il a de la gueule ça c'est très clair
htc lyon si tu veux il répond aux
standards des téléphones va pas au
standard à ce qui se fait en 2017
sauf un point et ce point là pour moi il
est dérangeant pour moi aujourd'hui un
smartphone doit répondre à deux
problématiques hyper importante allant
au delà du jeu est effectivement être un
téléphone d'avoir un os ou un android ce
qui se fait le plus android avec la
surcouche que ce soit de samsung ceux de
htc ou peu importe les deux chasse pour
moi les plus importantes aujourd'hui ça
va être d'une et l'écran ne le fait
d'avoir un écran de bonne qualité et
aujourd'hui effectivement des grands
écrans pour pouvoir visionner plus de
chances d'avoir des belles photos en
belles qualités regarder des vidéos qui
déchire ça pour moi c'est primordial et
le deuxième point le plus important
c'est un appareil photo de bonne qualité
ce soit l'appareil photo au dos de
l'appareil où l'appareil photo de face
se retrouve avec un bel appareil photo
au dos et enfin ce quelque chose de
pourri ou delphi sont dégueulasses
franchement ça très très peu d'intérêt
donc ça pour moi ce sont les deux points
primordiaux et le htc u11a à mon sens un
seul point c'est l'appareil photo le
l'écran c'est pas ça alors on va en
parler j'ai potassé mon sujet je me suis
renseigné les belles notes
j'ai extrêmement mal donc c'est pas
grave excusez moi c'est pas toi qui vas
délire c'est moi qui les aiment l'étape
et j'ai fait un petit comparatif par
rapport à effectivement un appareil
hyper qui était hyper attendu cette
année et qui est sorti c'est le samsung
galaxy et suite ce ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes produits mais d'un
point de vue consommateur effectivement
comme un moment ou un autre on doit
faire un choix entre un appareil ou un
autre savoir où est ce qu'on va mettre
son budget on se doit de comparer d'une
manière ou d'une autre alors pour moi
les deux produits sont enfin en tout cas
j'ai vu le et suite j'ai pu l'essayer
celui-là fatalement je les paye dans les
mains mais il a l'air vraiment de super
qualité alors je t'explique un petit peu
on va râler d'un point de vue déjà
technique et du point de vue du détail
alors le htc une 11
il a un design déjà en verre incurvé à
si tu vois bien en verre incurvée qui a
l'air vraiment effectivement super bo
qui est présenté en cinq couleurs sur
leur site mais pourtant on peut
l'acheter pour l'instant que le
précommander qu en trois couleurs on
peut le précommander sur un bleu clair
sur un bleu foncé et sur un noir il
était effectivement montré en couleur
rouge et en blanc avoir effectivement si
on peut l'avoir un peu plus tard dans
ses couleurs ou sont des couleurs qui
sont bloqués pour d'autres pays ça j'en
sais absolument rien pour l'instant
effectivement tu peux commander en trois
couleurs donc un design qui est vraiment
sympa quelque chose de très très faim
d'ailleurs il est tellement fan ils ont
supprimé le port jack aussi si tu veut
brancher des écouteurs c'est de l'ufdc
que tu vas pouvoir et qui me retrouver
pourquoi pas alors avant le port jack ça
m'emmerde toujours parce que quand tu es
par exemple équipé avec deux casques
bottes arrivé avec mon casque sony là tu
vois j'ai mon jack je suis emmerdé je
peux rien faire quand il veut brancher
un micro externe quand tu va tourner une
vidéo ou autre
tu peux pas m 2
du jack et ça franchement je trouve ça
chiant alors peut-être qu'il existe ou
qu'il existera des adaptateurs port usb
c'est jack peut-être s'il y en a pas en
tout cas pour moi c'est rédhibitoire je
prendrais pas alors je te disais un
design avec un verre incurvée une coque
arrière en effet irisé sont
effectivement en produits qui a l'air
très très très joli peut-être que je te
mettrai des screenshots sur l'écran
mandroux je montre la vidéo
à ce moment là une technologie qui a été
mise au point c'est ce qu'ils appellent
le head scène ça le relais 200 comment
ça marche que je trouve un vieux tout
bouge pas ça c'est mon vieux iphone tout
péter 5 c'est le principe du engine sais
que tu vas pouvoir avec une pression de
chaque côté tu va exercer
ça va être connue celle fera comme un
espèce de raccourcis alors par défaut
effectivement quand tu feras tu as
pression de chaque côté ça t'ouvre ira
l'appareil photo sur une première
pression est sur une deuxième pression
ça tu ouvriras l'appareil photo selphy
l'intérêt effectivement de cette
technologie qui est plutôt pas mal ça va
être de pouvoir personnaliser des
raccourcis sauf que ça reconnaît les
pressions courte et les pressions longue
donc ça te permettra effectivement de
personnaliser davantage ton téléphone et
de pouvoir par exemple vouloir ouvrir
instagram vouloir ouvrir twitter va leur
ouvrir autre chose tout en sachant que
ce système est ouvert aux développeurs
tiers
ce qui fait que une application pourra
très bien ce système pour pouvoir avoir
un raccourci dédié pour avoir une action
dédiée c'est un petit plus c'est pas
pour moi ce qui révèle tenir dans ce
téléphone mais c'est un petit plus que
quand même plutôt pas mal foutu que
surtout d'autant plus qu' on voit qu'il
ya une idée d'innovation il ya une idée
il ya une réflexion qui s'est posée par
rapport au fait de tenir le téléphone et
de se dire qu'est ce que je peux en
coûte congelés ah bah tiens si je presse
sur le côté
ça me fera une action pourquoi pas c'est
pas con alors l'écran de ce téléphone
c'est un écran 5,5 pouces quad hd qui
est en 1440 par 2005 160 pixels une
résolution de 534 ppp donc on est serein
ducron plutôt pas mal
alors après moi le grand grand regret
que j'ai par rapport à ça et c'est
effectivement le point qu'il me
satisfaisait ce qui se bâtissent ne va
pas je te disais pour moi il ya deux
points essentiels c'est l'écran et c'est
l'appareil photo cet écran pour moi il
n'y a pas chez vote un petit coup d'oeil
tu vois on n'est pas sur des écrans
borderless et ça c'est vraiment dommage
parce que aujourd'hui le borderless
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on va
retrouver partout c'est d'utiliser la
totalité de l'écran pour proposer
totalité du téléphone du smartphone pour
propose effectivement un grand écran et
je trouve ça dommage que le htc et 11 ne
l'est pas et ne le propose pas c'est à
mon sens le petit point qui manque c'est
vraiment la faiblesse de ce téléphone
c'est cet écran mais on en reparlera là
parce que à la fin je te ferai un global
de vue global entre les poids vraiment
positifs et les points d'avis négatifs
rédhibitoire pour ne pas prendre ce
téléphone bon côté processeur c'est une
machine qui est qui et hop qui marche
très bien avec un snapdragon 1 835 qui
cadencé à 2 45 giguère ce donc ça
fonctionne il est 8h bon
un super processeur super machine très
rapide pour l'instant on n'a absolument
rien dire de ce côté là 4 gigaoctets de
ram 64 giga de stockage qui extensible
tu peux monter jusqu'à 2 terreur 30 ou
en stockage sur ce téléphone donc c'est
vraiment bien
un capteur d'empreintes digitales en
façade pour déverrouiller rapidement ce
qui fonctionne aussi
il fonctionne sous android 7.1 nougat
avec une surcouche acheté chez htc
acheter chez htc acheter c'est parce que
bordel c'est hyper dur à dire est ce que
toi
htc 7 donc ça marche un clip et 67 qui
te protègera contre les éclaboussures à
l'eau douce et à la poussière
alors si on compare à au samsung galaxy
s 8 qui en ip 68 qui peut être immergé
pendant 30 minutes sous un mètre
cinquante d'eau bon voila tu vas très
clairement pas le faire attention quand
même moi j'ai vu une de leurs vidéos de
présentation qui ne pose un peu problème
où tu vois quelqu'un qui saute d'une
falaise et qui se filment et qu'ils
jettent dans l'eau normalement en ip67
tous qui craint ça craint le lot de
berre donc les garanties pour moi la
suisse s'ils peuvent te refusé en disant
qu'il ya des fous l'utilisation donc
c'est pas de la pub mensongère
parce que si tu le fais ça peut marcher
mais c'est quand même intéressant et
périls
je serais toi je ne fais pas une
batterie 3000 millions père heures avec
un système de charge rapide sa sécu
plutôt pas mal le coup de charges 3.0 ce
qui permet effectivement d'avoir un
téléphone qui se recharge rapidement
alors pas de recharge à induction on va
utiliser l'usb sait mais pour moi ça ça
pose aucun problème ça fonctionne pour
moi le point positif de ce téléphone
c'est vraiment l'audio ainsi tu es un
très grand fan de musique que tu aimes
que tu apprécies le bon son
bouger pour moi ça marche très très bien
ils ont mis en place ce qu'ils appellent
le système boom sund tu as quatre micros
autour du téléphone
ces 4 microgrammes est effectivement de
capter tout l'environnement musical et
sonore autour de toi et te de restituer
pour faire comme un son en trois
dimensions ça c'est vraiment très très
bien et en plus ces microbes au pouvoir
de l'utiliser dans le cadre d'une
réduction de bruit ils appellent ça sont
des écouteurs eu sonic avec une tonique
avec annulation active des bruits ça
s'est vraiment bien c'est à dire que les
micros vont capter tous les sons qui
autour de toi et ensuite les annuler et
créer un système d'annulation pour que
tu sois complètement en immersion avec
le son que écoute et que tu soit pas
parasité par le reste ça c'est vraiment
un point positif quand on veut écouter
de la bonne musique qu'on soit dans les
transports en commun je pense au métro
ont ce but c'est toujours beaucoup
beaucoup de bruit la mam allemand ça
devrait quand même temps fermer un peu
plus et qui profitent du son c'est pas
obligé de battre à fond pour pas être
emmerdé avec tous le sont pour toi donc
ça c'est vraiment un point positif
photo côté photo pour moi on est plutôt
bien capteur de 12 millions de pixels à
l'arrière ça correspond à ce qui se fait
dans la concurrence c'est très bien
point positif c'est le capteur à l'avant
16 mégapixels
ça c'est plutôt pas mal alors par contre
tu filme en full hd mais c'est bien
c'est bien parce que tu as une belle
définition kufra d'aider celles ci qui
sont bien surtout si on compare avec le
galaxy s suite qui lui et lui tend de 8
mégapixels donc avec une qualité quand
même inférieur donc ça sera positif pour
le htc eu aux alors côté poids il fait
168 grammes une luge à montfloures de 30
g de mon nom de 2,10 g excuse moi en
plus par rapport au galaxy et suit donc
je n'en sais rien du tout il ya leur
intelligence artificielle la htc sense
companion qui est compris dedans bon ça
c'est anecdotique
à mon sens c'est un produit qui est
dispo dès le mois de juin tu peut le
commander le recevoir à partir du 1er
juin si tu le commande sur le site d'htc
effectivement il annoncé en livrable à
partir du 1er juin ont pris 2 759 euros
c'est pas des conneries c'est un prix
qui est à mon sens à peu près correct un
peu moins cher d'une cinquantaine
d'euros par rapport au galaxy elle suit
maintenant il ya une vraie différence
entre les deux appareils
alors on aura pas du bluetooth ariane
tous 4.2 je te lis pas dit alors que le
galaxy sii un bluetooth 5.0 la vraie
différence par rapport à ce téléphone
pour moi elle se joue sur l'écran donc
on va parler des points positifs et des
points négatifs
les trois points positifs pour lesquels
il faut acheter ce téléphone le tout
premier c'est l'eau douce si vous êtes
un audiophile si vous êtes fan de
musique c'est un grand amateur musique
un grand consommateur de musique sur
différentes plateformes moins de p3 ou
peu importe ça c'est vraiment bien
si vous écoutez de la musique partout et
tout le temps ce système là
effectivement lieu sonic va être super
pour permettre vraiment d'éliminer tous
les sons parasites autour et de profiter
d'une qualité audio extraordinaire
d'autant plus qu' il y annonce un
système d' analyse d'oreille interne
avec une technologie sonar ce qui
permettra effectivement d'avoir un
profil audio personnalisés
et d'abord vraiment
une qualité de son optimale pour votre
oreille et ça c'est génial
l'autre point positif c'est la caméra de
cellfish une caméra l'en 16001 xs
permettra effectivement d'abord d'aider
celles vie de qualité
ça s'est vraiment bien parce que pendant
longtemps la caméra de saïfi a été
vraiment mis au second plan et à mon
avis c'est une très très grosse connerie
parce que la plupart des gens se
prennent en photo avec quelqu'un donc
quand tu prends un paysage c'est bien
d'avoir une note caméra de bonne qualité
mais dès lors que tu veux te prendre en
photo avec quelqu'un d'autant plus que
le seul fils devenu aujourd'hui la norme
il faut privilégier cette caméra à
l'avant et en 16 mégapixels ça c'est
très bien donc ça c'est le deuxième
point positif alors le troisième point
positif c'est la charge rapide
bon alors je le mets en pro positif
parce que c'est bien et on va pas passer
quatre heures à recharger un téléphone
mais c'est pas ce qui me pousserait à
l'acheter l'autre point positif plus ou
moins positif l ex le hajj scène ce
système effectivement de pression
sur des boutons fin des faux boutons de
pression latéral qui permettra
effectivement de paramétrer ton
téléphone pour avoir un raccourci ça
c'est plutôt pas mal foutu
alors maintenant voilà les points
négatifs premier point négatif pour mon
tout cas c'est l'absence de prise jack
notamment par rapport à l'existence de
le disait par rapport à mes cages par
rapport au fait que je puisse moi
brancher un micro sur mon téléphone
parce que il ça pour l'enregistrement ça
pour moi c'est rédhibitoire
le deuxième pouvoir et des victoires et
à mon avis est plus important c'est le
fait de pas avoir des crampes borderless
aujourd'hui ça devient un standard tu
vois alors tout le monde ne l'a pas un
c'est pas encore le standard absolu mais
ça va le devenir parce que on va très
bien pour bagarre des plus belles
qualités de photos des plus belles
qualités de vidéos une immersion de plus
en plus avec de beaux écrans si t'as pas
un très très bel écran avec une superbe
qualité et un grand écran c'est dommage
tu vois bien que le galaxy s utilise un
écran super amoled qui va prendre
quasiment la totalité du smartphone
c'est dommage que htc soit pas monter en
gamme alors il a fait cela on va coûter
beaucoup plus cher et le téléphone
aurait été pas forcément compétitif mais
vous savez dans le sait c'est le point
négatif de ce téléphone
autre point négatif le sans vraiment
l'être justement qui se justifie par
rapport au prix c'est d'avoir un
téléphone au prix de 859 euros
on est 50 euros moins cher qu'un galaxy
elle suit qui a un plus bas à l'écran
même si effectivement la caméra de celle
philippe moins bonne qualité voilà ça
pour moi c'est vraiment la grande
différence avec le f8 c'est cet écran et
c'est ce qui sera rédhibitoire si pour
toi à l'écran c'est pas rédhibitoire eh
ben pour téléphones qui est un petit peu
moins cher que le galaxy s que tu peux
te faire plaisir d'autant plus que ce
galaxy c'est d'acheter ses excuses moi à
muse a l'air d'être vraiment du super
qualité
on voit même un petit peu tout ce qu'on
pouvait dire aujourd'hui sur ce nouveau
téléphone de htc le htc lui aux qui pour
moi étant plutôt un bon produit alors si
tu es déjà jetés c'est si tu connais la
marque
si tu aimes les produits qu'ils font ben
je peux que de conseiller d'aller sur
téléphone parce que fondamentalement sa
dette une bonne bécane
si maintenant tu as un budget
à mettre dans un tel il fallait qu'ils
veulent faire plaisir et que l'audio
pour toi c'est pas prioritaire srec pour
50 euros plus avec le samsung a quand
même un truc qui est qui et hop
après si tu veux du moins cher tu peux
aller chez au nord tu as les téléphones
qui sont à 530 aux 550 euros
questionne bien qu'ils sont d'une bonne
qualité donc moi j'attends encore et
toujours la fameuse annonce du futur
iphone iphone 7 aces ou iphone 8
on sait pas encore comment ça va se
passer toujours est il que j'attends
vraiment cette annonce pour ensuite pour
le diriger sur un choix et pour dire
surtout quel sera le meilleur smartphone
de 2017
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle pourra apporter
quelques lumières par rapport aux
nouveaux modèles d'htc n'hésite pas à
lâcher leur groupe ou si tu as aimé la
vidéo avec toi à la chaîne pour plus de
contenus encore pour parler de teck pour
parler de blog pour parler de plein
plein de choses je traversais d'avoir
regardé la vidéo mais moi tout en
commentaire et dis moi ce que tu penses
de ce nouveau htc est ce que tu le
trouve bien pas bien comment tu le sais
tu toi par rapport à la concurrence
notamment aux grands téléphone de 2010
celle de samsung avec cette suite
je te remercie je te fais des bisous et
je te dis à très vite
[Musique]
et